[Music]
i ruled
[Music]
welcome to a very different and a very
exciting episode of kos and today
um i'm going to be talking about a
statue that i felt
is uh a grail i told you guys
that we'll be going forward and
transforming
my uh my collection and
to cap things off let's start off with
the incredible hulk xm studios
park transformation now
i i gotta give a shout out to uh todd
from spec fiction
uh i i suggest all you guys get a chance
to
go and purchase uh from todd expect
fiction
fast uh great prices
and reliable reliable uh
customer service so
without further ado let's get into
why i love the incredible hulk so much
um
it started off very early on for me
where
i uh fell in love with the character and
yeah you could say it was from the
incredible hulk
book see i i i wasn't born yet to
go through when the incredible hulk
first came
so when i got introduced to incredible
hulk that's when sal busimer was doing
like the rampaging hawk
and that's when hulk was a a mindless uh
brute so to say and
you know but he would save the day hawk
is the strongest one there
is and literally i thought there was no
one in the marvel comics that can
actually beat him to be honest with you
but um that what made me
fall in love with the character was the
tv show with bill bixby
and lou ferrigno and that gave me a
greater insight
of the character now of course we waited
for the transformations
when lou ferrigno was on screen but
bill bixby gave texture
character and depth to
david bruce banner now this is for you
jerry
david bruce banner is from the tv show
uh
robert uh bruce banner is
from the comic books i like david
wonder why anyway
so bruce banner was always trying to
rid himself and he had this reporter
that was following him
uh trying to get dirt on him trying to
figure out what was going on
and it just gave depth to the character
and it made the comic books more
enjoyable
for me to go to the comic books and read
about it and
that's where my love started with the
character
because you know he wanted to be left
alone he didn't want to trouble the
headache
and while bruce was trying to figure out
how he can change
so let's get into the statue
now this statue here has so much going
on
the reason why i needed this statue and
like the story i told you
david bruce better is first and foremost
in the picture the hulk is behind him so
it's like a whole transformation process
in
and the reason why i equate it with the
tv show is because
if you look there's a machine in the
back right
and he's like he's breaking out of the
machine on the show
uh david was hooked up to a machine
and he used that radiation
to get the gamma radiation to turn into
the hulk
now in the comic books the the complete
difference to that
is he uh was at a nuclear base
uh well uh a gamma radiation base and
they were
doing a gamma bomb and rick jones was
out there and he ran out there to save
jones life and in doing so he threw him
in the trench he took on all the gamma
radiation and he turned into the hulk
not the same way with the tv show
and not the same way with angly's
version of the hulk
uh you know and that's not canon but
again
david bruce banner is
depicted so well here you can see little
rips of him turning into the hall
the tie is going you can see
little bits of uh green under the shirt
the the shirt is like blowing up because
he's in agony the tires in flux
the face is in agony the glasses is
tilted the hands is through the hair
to be honest with you and and i don't
know if there's been other statues that
has
depicted uh you know
david bruce banner so well to be honest
with you
i think this is the best depiction of
him as a statue and as a character
and then we go into
the whole hulk himself the incredible
hulk himself
is absolutely amazing from
the presence this one-fourth statue the
presence of the hulk the tones in the
colors
the the musculature of the character
the iconic purple and with green
and then you see the the absolute
machine in the back this is real wiring
here
his foot is crushing the metal um
the machine is broken in pieces there's
wires hanging all over the place
and if it would have had like that
lighter feature where the sparks is
flying i think it would be absolutely
uh over the top this statue is
so incredible from the abs the face
the teeth on the incredible hulk the
eyes the the rampaging nature
of the incredible hulk you know to the
fingertips
to the toe nails the the rips in the
pants
now when you get to the rips and the
pants the same rips in the pants is
there
is the same rips in the pants that's
here this
is so amazing that so the texture on the
pants is here
the same texture on the pants as hair
it's an incredible statue from
all the the the artwork that went into
it
you know it's very big takes up a large
space
i love the fact that you know xm gives
you the plaques
that come with the statue this this
that's a great look that's a great feel
because you can put it in the front and
people can see you know your statues
being represented
this statue i i i have to rate it a
grail
it's a grill in my pieces uh this is the
centerpiece here as you see
uh and it would be like a hulk dorama
type of thing going on here fantastic
four that's a holding place
but again this incredible hulk statue
had to be front and center
and i gotta give a shout out again to
uh dolph castle x thor of golf castle x
he's an incredible driving force and
helping me get this statue
and todd made it happen so if you want
to see the live unboxing
i suggest you go to golf castle x i did
the live unboxing
live on the air there and that's why i
do my live unboxings
and then you guys get kos with the
synapses the pictures in the video
all right um also go to
lordsofgaming.net
where we have a ton of writers and stuff
like that but this is the part in the
video
where i'm gonna ask you to like follow
and subscribe
and hit that joy button hit that joy
button you know where that join button
is this is a new year
the join button is in the same place and
i want you to join
and follow me on my journey to
completing my
my statue collection all right you can
follow me on
iron lord's podcast sundays at 1pm
football season is over
and the lords is back with a new intro
new music stuff to rock to
man is incredible golf castle x friday
at 9 00 pm please go there like follow
subscribe there and also go to lords of
gaming.net
where we have a ton of writers ton of
opinion pieces
uh we are actually working so hard to
bring content to you guys
so please do me a favor stick around
watch the video
and then you can see more about the
statue more in depth
in close pictures video so you can know
exactly how great this statue is to me
and hopefully you love it too see you
next week
when i bring you a god
stay collected
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
so
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
so
[Music]
[Music]
so
[Music]
i rule
[Music]
you